there's some really good reasons why
some of this stuff was sealed uh and we
just i just talked about this on the
cleared hot podcast with uh with cara
smith
the the reason
one of one of the victims is a very very
well-known hollywood actress very well
known i mean if we were to say her name
um kara knows who she is or say her name
or if she was to have to show her face
everybody would know who she is why
can't you say her name um because right
now she is not one it's not my place
it's none of my business two she is a
victim of a crime sure
and she hold on she was she was she was
raped as a child
right and and one of the most prolific
cases in in history definitely one that
was covered by the media the most so
right now she is known as a hard-working
master of her craft
right if her name gets released publicly
she's now that girl who was raped by
epstein
which label do you want to wear for the
rest of your life is she a big big name
today big name so she's still active
working right now yes okay and now and i
respect you for not saying that and who
knows who's who knows who she is
a number of people okay a number of
people who who work in this space and
and this is this is what's really
important for us to keep in mind we all
want justice right yeah i mean
god built me for justice and to go after
bad people uh that that is that is why
he made me and put me on this earth and
so
um nobody nobody wants his justice more
than i do but it's not my justice to
have it's the victim's justice and so
every sing if any of those folks on that
flight law committed a crime it requires
a victim
per the constitution because that person
has a right to face their accuser
which is super important
if that victim chooses
not to have justice because they've
moved on right maybe years and years of
counseling it might have taken them 20
years to get over that and then we're
we're asking them to go into court
and rip that open
for us so we can have justice yeah it's
not ours to have and there's precedent
that even though they're victims it
still has an adverse effect on their
career you look at the actresses that
were involved in the nx ibm thing and oh
yeah the nexium you know the uh you know
they were branded and then you know
that that none of them had ever worked
again some of them became culpable in
the yeah the cult-like you know
atmosphere of it by recruiting after a
while but they were
yeah you know
listen man i mean one of the things you
know being in entertainment that it's
one of the scarier things about it but
this is like i've
met very very few executive producers
anybody that was ever willing to like do
a project especially an independent
project that didn't have that didn't get
their money from like some sort of
nefariousness me you know and i got to
be honest i'm going to be 100 i'm going
to be the only human being in america
honest if
i was asked 10 years ago by jeffrey
epstein to come down to his
his
island in the bahamas and hang out with
a bunch of supermodels and we'll talk
about financing your movie i'd have been
on that flight log
100 chance i'd have been on that flight
now i'd like to think that when i saw
what was going on there i wouldn't go
back a second or third or fourth time
but when you're in that industry
there are so few people willing to
greenlight your projects and they're you
know you talk you talk to people that
you don't know how they came about their
money sure right and then you have some
guy who's willing to and and listen
there's there's gonna be people in the
comments right now talking about i'm
appetito or i'm whatever and i'm not but
i'm telling you right now anybody that's
ever been to a bachelor party
you'd have i believe you'd have gone to
epstein island if you were if you were
invited anybody that's ever been to a
strip club would have gone to epstein
island if they were invited if
somebody's going to fly you down in
their private jet to an island to hang
out with women it's pretty tempting
right so i mean this idea you know one
of the things i don't like about the way
that this is covered is how everybody's
holier than now in the moment but it's
also like dude have you ever gone to a
strip club and asked the cid when you
were there i've never seen anybody
there's a big difference though there's
a big difference between
uh uh going to that island and
intentionally having an interest of
wanting to be with minors that he has on
the island those thousands those are two
different it's very important for you to
differentiate a thousand percent so
those are two different things so if
you're going with intent yeah you have
issues but if you're going saying dude
i'm putting the sickest party together
come on bye exactly yeah that's a
different conversation that you're
talking about but again we gotta there's
i think that was like just kind of like
his thing like i i don't like trump went
with them clint want them were those
guys banging chicks on his island i'm
willing to bet yes do i think they were
women though yes
like i don't know i'm not saying just
because you want to go party and have a
good time if you're bringing the shrimp
by example it doesn't mean you're like
14 year old girl i think that was just
his weirdest thing very very important
to like differentiate that especially
because and i'm only taking this from
the the netflix documentary that i saw
which which seemed very biased to begin
with anyway they talked about trump 90
times and clinton once right so you know
the
you know but
the women were like they were 17 and we
were told to tell people that we were 22
and it's horrible what happened to these
women i don't want to try to make it out
like it's not but then i'm also you know
i i look at what's happening and you
know bad baby turns 18 and makes a
trillion dollars off of her only fans
the day she turns 18 and everybody in
the world you know we have some sort of
weird kind of like
fetishization with young women when i
was growing up britney spears was 16
oops i did it again i mean like there's
a weird fetishization with that
almost jailbait kid right and you don't
we're not conditioned to like ask them
you go to this island wouldn't it be
like i'd almost feel like seriously i
would almost feel like it was
disrespecting my friend jeffrey to ask
the girls like are you you're you're 21
so i joined the army i joined the army
let me tell you what happened when i
joined the army uh uh joined the army
drill sergeant green our unit brings it
and brings us in
and says you go party in this town
here's what's going to happen you're
going to meet a lot of girls girls are
going to like guys in uniform just know
this but you're also a target
and you have to know that girls lie when
it comes down to their age
you have to id them
i'm like what are you talking you have
to id them he said you have to id them
before they come in to your place and by
the way how old are you i'm 18. he's 18.
i'm 18 years old perfect trash
so we're sitting there one of our guys
who had a house off uh uh uh off base we
all lived down base so on base you can't
even do it because they can't even make
it through the gate because the idea
everybody when they come through the
gate but san antonio brown this guy had
a place
off base so we go to the place to his
house there's a bunch of people there
next thing you know in the middle of it
one of the guys starts id and everybody
and one by one by one says you got to
leave you got to leave you got to leave
if you can't show your id this guy was
like the responsible guy everybody's got
to get out of here so i i think again
there's a big difference with some
people have the uh uh
the angle you took when you said you
know oops i did it again 16 years old
you know we put it out there who's that
on is that on the media is that on you
i'm not saying marketing is that on all
i'm saying the record
first of all i want to be really clear
what happened there is a travesty what
happened on that island is is a
nightmare i'm just saying that when to
his point cindy lauper gets on this list
and everybody's like well cindy laufer
is a pedo or cindy law for this or cindy
lopez that cindy lawford might have been
down there to talk about a project and
now she's lumped in with all this stuff
it's very very important like i you know
basically what you're saying gee just
because i'm with you 99 of the people on
these flights we're up to
not bad the point things that's that's
the one
that's why we need the forensic uh
accounting that's right investigation
because we don't know that we that i
mean do you think my numbers are no i
think you're off no i think what numbers
do you think it is
89
i'm thinking most people aren't
molesting children that's what i'm
guessing i think if you what's the
number then i think if you hang out with
skunks you start to stink um and i think
that there's a certain amount of of
personal responsibility like you you
have people in your life right business
partners that you know are doing shady
things and so you distance yourself from
them right you just uh hey sorry i'm too
busy you can't answer the phone right i
mean you may not necessarily be turning
them into the freaking irs but but
you're distancing yourself but you're
assuming they knew that's what he was
doing
i i think that i think that
over over decades and decades you you
start to you start to be able to see
what's going on with you literally
here's what it comes down to it's very
simple i mean let's why don't you go
investigate exactly where the money came
from that's what you got to do yeah the
guy
needs to go this guy's not around and
we'll go for all the money so the
question then becomes
the hesitancy of not wanting to follow
the money that's deeply concerning
that's the guy who's hesitant though
who's doing it though well
she's the first trial in history she's
the first human trafficker that was
convicted of trafficking to nobody
there was nobody else there was no she
she tried she she was the trafficker to
uh to epstein so that's that's how
they're saying that he was the engineer
yeah so so uh
uh
18 usc 1595 says that if you are uh
essentially getting any type of economic
value
um through
uh defrauding forcing or coercing
somebody else to do something right
where you're the recipient of the
economic value when you talked about
human trafficking you know
people don't know what that means and
let me give you a really easy way to
think about what human trafficking is
uh
you you perform labor you then get to
keep the the proceeds of your labor
right you you get remuneration for the
services and labor that you provide that
you chose to do freely right well yes
and in the whole philosophical
conversation around that but but whether
you're choosing to or not to you are
you are keeping the fruits of your labor
um human trafficking is when you provide
some torque some type of labor or
service and somebody else
is getting to keep the economic value
right now the economic value does not
have to necessarily mean cash
right we all know there's a whole lot of
economic value to influence
um right uh pelosi
there's a lot of of
uh economic value to uh narcotics as an
example is part of the way that uh human
trafficking work in this country so if
somebody's being
forced defrauded or coerced
into doing something for somebody else's
economic benefit you have human
trafficking and it doesn't matter what
that thing is what the service is what
the labor is
and that's that's really the port the
point that we focus on here so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye
[Music]